imaginen que para ser más interesante el
boliche se agrega un bucle vertical a la
pista de manera que tenemos que lanzar
la bola de boliche con mucha fuerza para
que pueda dar la vuelta vertical y
después llegar a donde están los pinos y
tirarlos
y para construir esto nosotros tenemos
que saber que en la parte alta de este
rizo la estructura tiene que resistir
cierta fuerza mínima y nos interesa
saber qué tan fuerte tenemos que
construir esta parte para resistir esa
fuerza no queremos que esto se rompa
porque no pudo resistir la fuerza de la
bola de boliche así que tenemos que
preguntarnos cuánta fuerza va a tener
que resistir este bucle para poder
soportar la fuerza que trae esta bola de
boliche mientras esta bola de boliche
pase por esta estructura vamos a
analizar este punto de arriba y a poner
algunas cantidades aquí arriba la bola
de boliche tiene una velocidad de 8
metros por segundo lo cual es bastante
rápido así que alguien lanzó esta bola
con mucha fuerza este bucle tiene un
radio de 2 metros y la bola de boliche
tiene una masa de 4 kilogramos
y ahora que tenemos estos números no os
podemos preguntar cuál será la fuerza
normal que va a existir entre el bucle y
la bola
en otras palabras cuál es el tamaño de
esta fuerza normal
esto es lo que tenemos que conocer para
saber si nuestra estructura es lo
suficientemente fuerte esto es lo que
tenemos que conocer para determinar si
esta estructura es lo suficientemente
fuerte como para contener esta bola de
boliche en movimiento y también es un
problema clásico de fuerza centrípeta
vamos a resolverlo que es lo primero que
tenemos que hacer pues dibujar el
diagrama de fuerzas siempre que
querramos conocer una fuerza tendremos
que dibujar un diagrama de fuerzas
cuáles son las fuerzas en esta bola pues
aquí tenemos la fuerza de gravedad que
va hacia abajo y la magnitud de la
fuerza de gravedad siempre está dada por
m por g en donde se representa la
magnitud de la aceleración debida a la
gravedad y m es la masa del objeto vamos
a tener una fuerza normal y comúnmente
se piensa que la fuerza normal siempre
apunta hacia arriba lo cual es un error
ya que si bien en muchas situaciones la
fuerza normal apunta hacia arriba por
ejemplo si nos encontramos en el suelo
la fuerza normal que es lo que
que atravesemos el suelo va a apuntar
hacia arriba pero esto no es lo que
ocurre en esta parte de arriba de la
estructura esta estructura no está por
debajo de nosotros al contrario está por
encima de esta bola esta fuerza normal
va a evitar que nos salgamos del bucle
así que va a apuntar hacia abajo y eso
es algo muy extraño para varias personas
pero debido a que la superficie está por
encima de esta bola la superficie va a
empujar hacia abajo la superficie sólo
pueden empujar si nos encontramos en el
suelo la superficie nos va a empujar
hacia arriba ya que la superficie está
por debajo de nosotros si la superficie
estuviera a un lado nos empujaría al
lado contrario si la superficie
estuviera a nuestra izquierda nos
empujaría hacia la derecha y si la
superficie está a nuestra derecha nos va
a empujar hacia la izquierda en otras
palabras las fuerzas normales siempre
van a empujar
así que la fuerza normal en la pista
sobre la bola va a ser hacia abajo y
viceversa la fuerza de la bola en la
pista o en el bucle va a ser hacia
arriba si esta bola fuera muy rápido y
esa estructura fuera de madera aquí
veríamos que se astilla ya que habría
demasiada fuerza empujando en esta
estructura pero si estamos analizando a
la bola la fuerza en la bola que viene
de la pista va hacia abajo y una vez que
ya dibujamos nuestro diagrama de fuerzas
el siguiente paso normalmente si
queremos encontrar una fuerza es usar la
segunda ley de newton y para mantener
nuestros cálculos sencillos normalmente
usamos la segunda ley de newton en una
sola dimensión podría ser en la
dirección vertical en la dirección
horizontal o en la dirección centrípeta
y justo esta es la que vamos a usar en
este caso ya que la fuerza normal está
apuntando hacia el centro de la ruta
circular y ya que la fuerza normal es la
fuerza
queremos encontrar vamos a usar la
segunda ley de newton en la dirección
centrípeta y recuerden que se entre p
está es una palabra elegante para
referirnos a todo lo que va hacia el
centro del círculo así que la
aceleración centrípeta va a ser igual a
la fuerza neta centrípeta entre la masa
del objeto
de este objeto que está en el círculo y
la aceleración centrípeta siempre puede
escribirse como la rapidez al cuadrado
entre el radio del círculo o de la ruta
circular que está siguiendo el objeto y
esto debe ser igual a la fuerza neta
sentri que está dividida entre la masa y
aquí debemos recordar cómo manejamos los
signos de este lado tenemos un signo
positivo porque siempre tenemos un signo
positivo para nuestra aceleración
centrípeta y nuestra aceleración
centrípeta siempre apunta hacia el
centro del círculo así que todo lo que
apunte hacia el centro del círculo va a
tener un signo positivo vamos a resolver
esto y es justo en esta parte donde se
complica un poco el problema para
ciertas personas así que debemos tener
cuidado con lo que escribamos aquí
cuáles son las fuerzas centrípetas para
encontrarlas lo único que tenemos que
hacer es ver nuestro diagrama de fuerzas
las fuerzas en este diagrama son la
fuerza normal y la fuerza de gravedad
veamos la fuerza de gravedad
esta va a ser una fuerza centrípeta y
esa es la primera pregunta que tenemos
que hacernos ver si esta fuerza siquiera
la tenemos que tomar en cuenta o no y
para responder a esta pregunta nos
preguntamos esta fuerza se dirige hacia
el centro del círculo o hacia el centro
de la ruta circular y si si lo hace así
que aquí incluimos la fuerza de gravedad
y ya que se dirige hacia el centro del
círculo y no hacia afuera o hacia el
lado contrario va a tener entonces un
signo positivo de igual manera para la
fuerza normal vemos que también apunta
hacia el centro de la ruta circular
entonces también la vamos a incluir y
con signo positivo y ahora ya puedo
despejar mi fuerza normal lo resuelvo
algebraica mente multiplico ambos lados
por la masa y resto m por g en ambos
lados de la igualdad esto me va a dar m
por b al cuadrado entre r - m por g
si ponemos los números nos va a quedar
que son 4 kilogramos
por 8 metros por segundo todo al
cuadrado no hay que olvidar lo dividido
entre el radio que es de 2 metros menos
la masa del objeto que es de 4
kilogramos por la aceleración de la
gravedad que es 9.8 metros por segundo
al cuadrado y si lo resolvemos todo nos
va a dar 88.8 newtons esta es la
cantidad de fuerza hacia abajo que se
ejerce sobre la bola debido a la pista
pero por la tercera ley de newton
nosotros sabemos que esa fuerza es la
misma que se está ejerciendo desde la
bola hacia la pista hacia arriba así que
con cualquier material que hagamos esta
pista más vale que resista los 88.8
newtons si es que queremos que las
personas puedan hacer girar esta bola
con una rapidez de 8 metros por segundo
ahora déjenme hacerles otra pregunta qué
pasa si esta bola ahora llega hasta este
otro punto
será la fuerza normal en este punto de
aquí será mayor que la fuerza normal que
ya calculamos será menor o será igual
bueno para saber lo tendremos que
dibujar un diagrama de fuerzas aquí
tendremos la fuerza de gravedad que
nuevamente estará apuntando hacia abajo
y de nuevo su magnitud va a ser igual a
m por g la masa por la magnitud de la
aceleración debido a la gravedad y
también tendremos una fuerza normal pero
en esta ocasión la fuerza normal no va a
estar apuntando hacia abajo recuerden
que las superficies empujan hacia afuera
y si esa superficie está a la izquierda
de la bola esa superficie la va a
empujar hacia la derecha así que nuestra
fuerza normal va a ir hacia la derecha
supongamos que este bucle está muy bien
aceitado y no vamos a tener fuerza de
fricción aquí en este caso solamente
tendremos estas dos fuerzas y cuál será
la respuesta a nuestra pregunta cuánto
valdrá la fuerza normal en este caso
será mayor menor o igual
la fuerza normal que calculamos cuando
se encontraba en la parte de arriba de
la pista bueno yo les puedo decir que
seguro va a ser más grande y bastante
más grande ya que cuando ponemos aquí
las fuerzas centrípetas sólo vamos a
incluir a aquellas fuerzas que tienen
una dirección radial es decir que van
hacia el centro de la ruta circular o
hacia afuera de esa ruta circular si se
dirigen hacia adentro del círculo serán
positivas y si se dirigen hacia fuera
del círculo serán negativas y si no
apuntan hacia adentro o hacia afuera
radialmente de este círculo entonces no
las vamos a tomar en cuenta porque no
son fuerzas centrípetas en otras
palabras no están causando esta
aceleración centrípeta así que para este
caso la gravedad ya no es una fuerza
centrípeta ya que la fuerza de gravedad
ya no está apuntando hacia el centro del
círculo en este punto la fuerza de
gravedad es tangencial al círculo no se
dirige ni hacia adentro y hacia afuera
por lo que no la vamos a tomar en cuenta
parece
acción centrípeta solamente va a tratar
de darle más rapidez a esta bola pero no
le va a cambiar la dirección así que no
contribuye a que esta bola se mueva en
una ruta circular así que no la
incluimos en este cálculo y ahora que
despejemos la fuerza normal ya no vamos
a tener este factor de la gravedad aquí
por lo que ya no vamos a restar este
término aquí lo que hará que nuestra
fuerza normal sea mayor es más la
rapidez de esta bola va a aumentar en
comparación a la rapidez que tenía aquí
arriba al ir cayendo esta bola la fuerza
de gravedad va a aumentar su rapidez y
ahora que la rapidez es mayor y no le
estamos restando nada pues la fuerza
normal va a ser aún más grande al menos
comparándola cuando estaba en la parte
de arriba del bucle en resumen cuando
queremos resolver un problema de fuerza
centrípeta lo primero que hacemos es
dibujar nuestro diagrama de fuerzas y
después aplicar nuestra segunda ley de
newton en alguna dimensión
y decidimos aplicar la segunda ley de
newton en la dirección centrípeta es
decir hacia el centro del círculo
tenemos que asegurarnos de solo incluir
aquellas fuerzas que están en esta
dirección ya sea radialmente hacia el
centro del círculo en cuyo caso tendrán
un signo positivo o aquellas que van
radialmente afuera del círculo en cuyo
caso tendrán un signo negativo y si no
apuntan radialmente hacia adentro o
hacia afuera del círculo no las vamos a
tomar en cuenta al menos cuando usamos
la dirección centrípeta